can you please tell me
what
hunger ward the last hope between war
and starvation is about
hunger ward is a is a short documentary
um that really is an attempt to
illustrate
the effects of
the conflict on yemen specifically on
civilians
and we document it in in both the north
and the south of the country because
it's a bifurcated country the south is
held by the globally recognized
government in the south which up until
last week
was run by
at least on the surface by president
hadi
um holed up in riyadh
he was essentially
removed from office last week by
most people would agree
the emiratis and the saudis to put in
place a presidential council
so we wanted to show that starvation was
happening in very similar fashions both
in the south and the north so and we
wanted to do this film
because
um so few people in the west know
anything about the conflict in yemen nor
the us's complicity in it and so my
intent with the project was try to bring
it to a larger western audience as an
attempt to intervene and change the
political status quo which allows
the use of starvation in yemen to
continue so us complicity
who are the bad guys
now
the world
unfortunately cannot be painted in black
and white of good guys and bad guys
but for the purpose of conversation
who is um
doing
causing suffering in the world in this
situation
who started the war why
and then of course the roots of war go
back in history yeah but let's start at
the
at the top
well there are bad actors and there are
less bad actors right i mean i think
that's always the case in war probably
and everybody loses in war yeah
i concur with that statement um
in the case of the sort of the status
quo in yemen right now
it's a completely asymmetrical war um
and so the saudi coalition which is made
up of primarily saudi arabia the
emiratis united states
france
britain supplying weapons but it's
really driven um and catalyzed by saudi
arabia
and it's asymmetrical to a great extent
just because of the incredible firepower
by air that the saudis um used
continuously to pummel northern yemen
when i was there
the the sheer volume of air strikes is
is hard to describe and we show the
result of only one in the film really
but it's an asymmetrical war the de
facto authorities of the north um on sir
allah also known as the houthi rebel
group you know they um
they don't have an air force right they
have a drone force but they don't have
an air force and so it's a from a
military standpoint it's completely
asymmetrical the saudis really don't
commit troops to the ground they use
only proxies to fight on the ground what
is the narrative
they use to justify war
so there's a story on every side
in war
some of it
is grounded in truth some of it is not
at all grounded in truth
also known as propaganda
what's the narrative used by the saudis
for this war
the saudi line is essentially that the
houthis are an illegitimate government
and that that it's really a proxy rule
war between iran who supports the
houthis nominally
and the rest of the world that's the
saudi narrative the reality is something
altogether different while the houthis
do receive support from iran this is a
war
started by and sustained by mbs in saudi
arabia who's mbs muhammad bin salman
and who is he he is the son of the ruler
of saudi arabia
what's his power i'm asking basic dumb
questions he's the de facto ruler of the
military and uh yes he controls the
control of the country several years ago
even though he on the surface you know
is not the rule of saudi arabia he is
he's the crown prince and sorry to
interrupt dolphin but
who is he as a man
what's your sense of this yeah so you
know i've never met him and i i likely
will never meet him hopefully
but he is i know a lot about him through
his actions sort of in the mena region
the middle east and north africa region
and um
he is one of three in my view as an
american sitting here in the u.s
three people in the world that
i think
has caused such an incredible volume of
misery and suffering and murder on this
planet
that um i think
if
if he weren't around the world would be
a lot better place and and i'm not a
violent person by nature but there are
three human beings that i think
um the world would be better off without
do you mind before i ask other questions
mentioning the three oh yeah assad is
one in syria and that comes out of an
earlier project that i did in syria and
turkey
and and what i saw
assad as a as a ruler do to his own
people
um
and putin would be the third
those three human beings are uh
murderers on a scale
uh beyond imagining
on mbs
are you able to think as a documentary
filmmaker as a human being as a scholar
as a thinker with an open mind about a
man like that who does evil onto the
world and what that must feel like to be
in inside the mind of that man so
basically
consider his world view with most evil
people
with all people probably but with people
who do evil onto the world they think
they're doing good
yeah they're the hero of their own story
right yeah and so to be able to place
yourself
i feel like for me to understand a
person i have to
literally like the way actors kind of
have to do um
you know live inside the body of the
person they're trying to study inhabit
the character inhabit the person yeah
are you able to do that or because you
uh are also studying the people who
suffer
as a result as a consequence of their
actions you just you put put them in a
box
and you say i hate the person in that
box
they're going to move on this goes back
to your black and white statement at the
beginning right it's like
the world as a whole of course you know
is every gradation of gray right my
background is theater likes and so i was
trained long before i picked up a camera
to inhabit other characters right i have
two degrees in theater and so that level
of sort of like
walking in other people's shoes and
trying to understand and empathize with
their world view
is fundamental to how i live my life and
how i do my work so in the case of those
three that i named assad mbs and putin
yeah i can i can go there and think
through how they came to be who they are
right uh from afar right and and after i
go through that process
i still don't think there's any way
that
one can justify
what they've done
we're going to talk
about each of those people for sure well
i'm not an expert on well any of them
you're a human being which makes you
a uh partial expert on human nature
because nobody's an expert you're as
good as anyone else
anybody who actually cares a camera and
listens and observe others isn't
especially an expert of human nature
um who's willing to take that leap and
truly understand somebody of any level
not leaders i feel like to understand a
leader you have to first understand
humans and to understand humans you have
to see humans that they're worse than
their best
which is something that
you've definitely done so let's let's
stick on hunger ward this lens that
you've chosen to look at this is through
a single maybe maybe you can speak to
that
you've mentioned
the starvation as a result of war
what is the documentary like what is the
lens you've chosen to
give the world a peek at the results at
the suffering that's a result of this
war
people a lot of times will ask me if
they've seen hunger ward
you know
um
they ask where the hope is right um you
you read the the byline earlier
um the last hope
and
what i try to focus on in in many of my
films including hunger ward is
in in the very difficult
context of war as the cases in hunger
ward in yemen
i i look for hope and i look for
inspiration and i do that through people
who are doing incredible things under
the most difficult circumstances
so
when i set out to do a film about
starvation
in yemen right
i mean just listen to that statement
where's the hope there right and yet
what i found what i discovered were
human beings that we could tell the
story through
who are incredible inspirational human
beings doing amazing things every day
one of those is makia maji a nurse
practitioner in the north of the country
at a small rural clinic and another is
dr aida al-sadiq who's a pediatrician in
the south of the country and so we chose
to tell the story sort of through their
experiences as caregivers
devoting their lives to try to save this
entire
cohort this entire generation of
children that has been born into
starvation
and that's an incredible difficult task
but equally inspirational to watch these
human beings devote every minute of
every day
to save a child i mean in my view
nothing is more important than that
action maybe on that point real quick
so there is suffering at scale
starvation at scale there's
i mean the numbers um
maybe you can mention in yemen what are
the numbers in terms of people and
starvation but
from a perspective of a nurse
practitioner or a doctor
you always have you're treating one
person in front of you
so how do you make sense of that
calculus
of like there's a huge number of people
suffering
and then there's just the person in
front of you
is that all we can do as humans is just
to help one person at a time is that the
right way to think
and to approach these problems or can
you actually make sense of the numbers
speaking just as a
human being i think um the scale of
suffering is so great in yemen
that
um
i i think i'd be overwhelmed right if i
focused on that scale you know you've
probably heard that you know a child
dies every 75 seconds in yemen from
hunger right so we've been sitting here
how long you know 35 minutes or so
that's a good handful of children that
have already passed away
so to overcome sort of i think that
danger of psychic numbing which can
happen when you think about suffering on
such a large scale
as a filmmaker as a human being
i have to focus in on the individuals
and those those human beings in front of
me and i think that's exactly what dr
al-sadiq and makia do to keep going each
day
and one of the amazing things about
these two
healthcare providers that we showcase in
the film is that
they treat anyone who shows up
right they don't have to have money they
don't have to have any resources they
just have to get to the clinic or the
hospital
and it's incredibly moving
to see
sort of the flexibility of their
thinking in terms of how they make that
work
makia for example i saw her in the north
of the country it's an incredibly rural
clinic that she works at so so it's like
a magnet for all the cases in the north
of the country people come from hundreds
of kilometers away sometimes for
specialty treatment of of pediatric
malnutrition
and i
one time i saw a child come in
and it was a male relative that brought
this young girl in
and you know just because of
sort of the gender dynamics in yemen you
know there had to be
a parent or a relative there to stay
with the child while they're at the
clinic and it was a male relative and so
you know what many doctors in that
instance would do would just turn them
away and instead what makia did is she
walked into one of the rooms talked to
one of the other mothers and convinced
them to become the temporary guardian
essentially of this child until a female
relative could could arrive so you know
she's flexible she she finds solutions
rather than allowing the problems to
deter solutions one child at a time yeah
yeah one shot at a time
you mentioned that you saw
a child die in front of you
so when you're filming this as a
filmmaker
what's that like
psychologically
philosophically
creatively as a filmmaker as a
storyteller
what
what do you do there as a human and as a
filmmaker
oh what's that whole experience like
because you get to like you said you
take it to the whole journey
of a starving mother giving birth to a
starving child
um it's not something i want to film
um it's not something that i
certainly
wanted to happen or seek out um but it
happened
and the sad truth is that it happens
every week at that hospital
and so
when it happened in this instance
i felt an incredible responsibility to
do justice to that reality
to acknowledge that a child had just
died of starvation related causes
and and to find some way if the parents
wanted us to
to integrate that into this story we'd
bring back to
a western audience
and and you know i
i've
filmed
many difficult things over the years and
um
usually i really
love filming
and i didn't love filming hunger ward it
was not uh
a process that i enjoyed on any way
should perform sadly
because of the content because you know
who wants to watch a child die in front
of them i don't
but i did and i had to
and and when that happened i felt an
incredible responsibility again
to go deep right to go deep with that
family to to tell the story of this
hospital
um with every sort of
ounce of focus and
talent that i could bring to the story
because people should know
that um
children are dying of starvation right
now as we sit here and that that doesn't
have to happen and it is happening
because of political dynamics that we
can intervene on
is there times you wanted to
walk away
quit the telling of the story
come back to the united states
where
you can be just
um appreciate
the
um the wonderful comfort you can have
just sitting there and having food and
and uh
freedom to do whatever you want
those kinds of things doesn't have to be
the united states anyway yeah in a lot
of places in the world
well that dynamic of sort of like
survivors guilt you know on some level
it definitely exists one of the hardest
things about filming hunger forward
actually was
eating
right because we were in these
malnutrition clinics they're called
tfc's therapeutic feeding centers
where um you know
over a long period of time children lost
the ability to eat normal food right
um and couldn't digest it and just you
know were literally starving and
the the practitioners were trying to
bring them back to a state of of
thriving
but to leave those clinics right and to
go to our camp or to go to our hotel
and then to have access to food right
because we could buy food on the streets
and in the hotels
um
i mean it was a very intentional act
throughout the course of the shoot to
look at a piece of bread right or to
look at a bowl of rice
and and think about that child in the
tfc and think about how the privilege of
having that bowl of rice that i could
eat and digest
so it certainly every day
um helped me appreciate right the
privilege i had every bite you take with
everybody uh absolutely and so so i
wouldn't call it guilt it wasn't exactly
guilt but it was definitely mindfulness
right about meditate on on the suffering
of people who yeah who can't that's
right exactly so that knowledge sort of
it was it was catalytic in some ways it
sort of moved us forward really wanting
to
shape the most powerful story we could
because we were surrounded by so much
suffering every day
how did that
film in that movie change you as a man
as a human being
you've filmed a few difficult
documentaries
that one
is a heavy one when you think of the
person you wore before you filmed it
and now when you wake up every morning
you look yourself in the mirror
how's that person different
every
documentary i do changes me in a
different way
like i am not
static in that sense right and preformed
it's like i change with every project
because
so many of them are
difficult and challenging right and so
in order to do them
i have to allow myself to change and be
changed by them in the case of hunger
ward
you may remember
the girl omama
um who's the the 10 year old girl who we
showcase in
in odden in the south of the country
and um you know
we we were there when she was admitted
to the hospital
and
when she was admitted you know sh this
10 year old girl weighed 24 pounds and
she could
barely stand up
and um
we started you know with the permission
of the family to start to document
um
her treatment and to see what would
happen with this young girl who is so
severely malnourished
and we watched her
be treated by the the nurses and the
doctors
in sadaka hospital and slowly over the
course of uh a couple weeks
we saw her
change we start her start to sort of
gain strength and start to recover
and she also watched the caregivers
very carefully
and i watched her
watch them
and um
i'll never forget there was a moment
where
um
about two and a half weeks i think into
her treatment we walked into a room
and i saw her
offering a cap full of water
to
another younger child who was also
starving right this the shot's actually
in the film
and and so to see omama this child who's
starving
giving sustenance to a younger
more vulnerable child who was also
starving
moved me deeply
right
so i saw
her
learn from the caregivers around her
right and as a human being as a
filmmaker i was incredibly inspired by
omama that capacity for compassion is
there even within a 10 year old girl
who's starving right and so so you asked
what changed me um that's one moment
right i i rather than being crushed by
such heavy content it was actually the
opposite where i came away inspired by a
ten-year-old girl and you know i didn't
anticipate that i didn't think that's
what this content would do but it's what
it did it it reinforced for me
sort of this incredible capacity we all
have as human beings right to do good
right to even within the most difficult
circumstances to choose
who we become and what we do
and and and a ten-year-old girl taught
me that to reinforce that for me
you